[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
consacré à l'élection présidentielle en
France pour ce second tour c'est à
nouveau un duel entre Emmanuel Macron et
Marine Le Pen un duel qui va durer deux
semaines les deux candidats ont démarré
la bataille sur le terrain dans le Nord
pour Emmanuel Macron dans l'Yonne pour
Marine Le Pen on va revenir tout de
suite sur les résultats définitifs du
premier tour vous allez le voir avec
27,84% des voix pour Emmanuel Macron
arriver donc en tête il améliore son
score de quatre points par rapport à
2017 Marine Le Pen en deuxième position
avec 5 points de retard à 23,15% des
voix elle progresse néanmoins de trois
points par rapport à 2017 Jean-Luc
Mélenchon en troisième position lui a
gagné 1,6 points par rapport à sa
précédente campagne avec
21,95% des voix ensuite Éric Zemmour
7,07% des voix Valérie Pécresse 4,7
Yannick Jadot 4,6 Jean Lassalle 3,3
Fabien Roussel vous allez le voir avec
2,2% des voix Nicolas Dupont-Aignan de
0,5 Anne Hidalgo 1,75% des voix Philippe
Poutou 0,77 Nathalie Arthaud zéro
virgule soit
0,56% des voix alors quelle est la
sociologie de ce duel Macron Le Pen
est-ce que la France et la France des
cadres et des retraités contre la France
des employés et des ouvriers la France
des villes contre celle des campagnes la
France de l'intégration européenne
contre la souveraineté nationale les
électeurs de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sont-ils
des faiseurs de roi dans ce nouveau face
à face Macron Le Pen Marine Le Pen
peut-elle gagner on va poser la question
à nos invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à
mes côtés Pascal Perrineau bonsoir
solitologue également auteur du
populisme bienvenue dans le débat en
face de vous Mathieu douareb bonsoir
directeur étude de Ipsos on vous connaît
bien FRANCE 24 vous étiez avec nous à
toute la nuit dernière bienvenue à vous
dans le débat avec nous également Claude
veille l'analyse chroniqueur politique
bienvenue également à vous et puis on
doit avoir donc Judith Wein Rob qui est
23 pardon qui est journaliste au Figaro
qui va nous rejoindre dans un petit
instant coincé dans son taxi et on va
retrouver tout de suite notre envoyé
spécial Clovis Casali qui suit Marine Le
Pen dans l'Yonne on va d'abord écouter
Marine Le Pen
quand on sait qu'on a raison il faut
continuer à se battre envers et contre
tout
malgré la concurrence malgré parfois
quelques comportements personnels
d'anciens amis qui nous ont déçus malgré
les difficultés qui ont été mises sur
notre route pour trouver les moyens de
financement de la campagne malgré les
difficultés qui ont été les nôtres dans
la recherche de parrainage je sais que
ça paraît loin quand on est en campagne
tout ça paraît très loin mais nous avons
surmonté tous ces obstacles grâce à nos
convictions et grâce aussi évidemment à
notre expérience on retrouve tout de
suite le vice cazalik ici Marine Le Pen
Clovis bonsoir Marine Le Pen a-t-elle la
stratégie du espèce de référendum anti
Macron
absolument et se déplacement était en
déplacement surprise dans l'Yonne en
fait ce qui semble s'être passé c'est
qu'elle a vu que le président Emmanuel
Macron s'était rendu dans les
Hauts-de-Seine donc elle a convoqué elle
a organisé à la dernière minute se
déplacement ici à soucis l'agriculteur
s'est réalisé qu'elle a rencontré a été
averti à 12h30 que Marine Le Pen allait
débarquer avec beaucoup beaucoup de
journalistes et ici elle a vraiment
voulu se présenter comme la candidate du
peuple la candidate du monde rural elle
a déclaré que pendant des années les
gouvernements successifs n'avaient rien
fait pour sauver les agriculteurs et
elle a déclaré que Emmanuel Macron et
bien c'était la régression de la France
qu'il fallait sauver le pays et qu'elle
avait les épaules pour le faire elle
était vraiment à l'écoute de
l'agriculteur céréalier qui avait une
exploitation de 250 hectares elle a
essayé d'écouter un petit peu ses
problèmes ce qu'il avait à lui dire et
notamment au niveau du pouvoir d'achat
le pouvoir d'achat un thème central dans
sa campagne le monde rural vraiment
compte pour Marine Le penchon toute la
campagne elle a décidé un petit peu
délaisser les grandes villes pour aller
avec ces bus dans des coins où les
politiques les hommes politiques on peut
l'habitude d'aller c'est toute une
stratégie elle la candidate du peuple
contre le candidat des élites comme elle
l'appelle Emmanuel Macron merci Clovis
Casali qui suit donc Marine Le Pen
Emmanuel Macron de son côté est
également sur le terrain il a démarré ce
matin par un banc de foule dans le Nord
on l'écoute
ça fait cinq ans que je suis président
et je regarde aussi les fractures qu'il
y a dans le pays les colères et j'ai
entendu le message de toutes celles et
ceux qui
ont exprimé des fois extrêmes et je le
redis y compris celles et ceux qui ont
pu voter pour Madame Le Pen je sais
qu'il y a des gens qui voteront pour moi
ou qui sont pour faire barrage au Front
national ça veut pas dire qu'il
soutiendront de mon projet mais je veux
essayer de convaincre des gens de faire
avec moi et donc peut-être en effet de
compléter mon projet d'aller plus loin
de bâtir
est au QG d'Emmanuel Macron
pour Emmanuel Macron il n'est plus
question de déléguer dans cette période
de l'entre-deux-tours le président
sortant veut faire lui-même campagne il
a annoncé d'ailleurs cette semaine pas
moins de trois déplacements et dans les
régions et pas n'importe quelle région
puisqu'il était aujourd'hui dans les
hauts de France il sera demain dans le
Grand Est en fin de semaine il sera en
région provençale peu Côte d'Azur donc
au lendemain du 1er tour Emmanuel Macron
veut faire campagne sur les terres même
de Marine Le Pen il l'a dit aujourd'hui
à Dena à la mi-journée il cherche à
convaincre et à ramener l'électorat de
Marine Le Pen vers lui en se
positionnant comme le seul candidat
crédible du pouvoir d'achat bien sûr à
l'issue de ce premier tour Emmanuel
Macron peut compter sur le soutien d'un
certain nombre de candidats malheureux à
l'issue de ce premier tour mais il le
sait ce ne sera pas suffisant la vraie
réserve de voie est à trouver chez les
mélenchonistes et c'est d'ailleurs tout
le sens de son déplacement en fin de
semaine à Marseille puisque c'est à
Marseille que Jean-Luc Mélenchon était
arrivé en tête du premier tour mais pour
convaincre ces électeurs là et bien il
faudra se positionner en candidat
républicain en candidat du rassemblement
et c'est ici au QG ce qu'on essaie de
faire de créer l'image du candidat du
rassemblement en tout cas parmi les
figures politiques proches d'Emmanuel
Macron que nous avons pu rencontrer des
ce matin au QG de campagne d'Emmanuel
Macron et bien le credo reste le même
qu'avant le premier tour rien n'est joué
il reste bien évidemment mobilisé parce
qu'elle perrineo est-ce qu'on est dans
une redite une réplique de 2017 avec ce
nouveau duel non au-delà du en effet de
l'identité de Marine Le Pen et
d'Emmanuel Macron on n'est pas dans une
redite parce que le rapport de force à
évoluer au fond en 2017 il y a eu la
première phase de la destruction du
système de partie qui avait organisé
la Cinquième République et là on est
dans la deuxième phase c'est à dire on
est dans une phase de déstructuration
beaucoup plus importante qu'en 2017 en
2017 tout de même la droite c'était 20%
des lecteurs qui s'étaient retrouvés
derrière François Fillon cette fois-ci
vous l'avez vu ces véritablement
l'implosion la dispersion et pour
construire sa majorité il va falloir
aussi bien pour Marine Le Pen que pour
Emmanuel Macron allait pêcher un peu
partout et aller pêcher dans des terres
qui sont a priori des terres
contradictoires on le voit bien pour le
président de la République il est il est
en ce moment où aujourd'hui il a cherché
à parler à l'électorat populaire
du nord-est qui s'est retrouvée
massivement derrière Marine Le Pen et
puis après coup de barre à gauche on va
aller à Marseille pour draguer les
électeurs mélenchonistes mais madame
Marine Le Pen est devant la même
difficulté parce qu'il va falloir en
effet rassemble derrière elle ce qui est
nouveau par rapport à 2017 cette réserve
qui est toi-même conséquente cette
réserve d'électeurs hémoriens et puis il
faut qu'elle s'adresse également elle
aux électeurs de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
parce qu'elle étant donné la puissance
de Mélenchon 3e position Marine Le Pen
ne peut pas envisager de créer une
surprise s'il n'y avait pas aller 40%
d'électeurs de Mélenchon qui l'a choisi
au second tour
réalisée sur la sociologie électorale
est-ce qu'il y a une fracture
territoriale Macron Le Pen ça c'est
effectivement c'est j'ai envie de dire
d'ailleurs pas vraiment nouveau parce
qu'effectivement on l'avait en 2017 pour
le coup c'était peut-être encore plus
net aux européennes de 2019 parce que là
on voit vraiment comme les deux forces
arrivées en tête étaient les mêmes alors
pas dans le même ordre mais avec des
niveaux assez proches on avait vraiment
un clivage effectivement le nord-est
contre le Sud-Ouest déjà ça c'est très
très vieux maintenant et puis surtout
sociologique en fait c'est beaucoup plus
sociologique des choses c'est vrai quand
même que c'est très corrélé avec le
niveau de diplôme le niveau de revenu
et alors aussi on le dit pas assez avec
l'âge c'est à dire que l'électorat de
Macron est quand même nettement plus âgé
en moyenne quel électorat de Marine Le
Pen et surtout c'est très très net chez
les jeunes actifs après les très jeunes
électeurs là pour le coup ils sont
beaucoup plus répartis mais l'autre
chose que Jean-Luc Mélenchon cette fois
les jeunes ils ont probablement joué un
rôle important dans la remontait la
fameuse remontada parce que ils étaient
plutôt partis comme toujours ça c'est
pas nouveau non plus objectivement vers
Europe Écologie Les Verts et puis au
dernier moment ils ont eu un réflexe de
vote utilise lui aussi visiblement ce
qui est assez inédite dans un électorat
jeune en revanche non ce qui est ce qui
est vraiment caricatural aujourd'hui
c'est que les lecteurs Macron c'est
vraiment alors là à la fois
sociologiquement et géographiquement les
lecteurs à droite je me suis amusé à
superposer sa carte à celle de Giscard
en 74 et si vous retirez Bordeaux parce
qu'à l'époque abandonnes et que la
Bordeaux c'est très Mâcon c'est
exactement la même carte j'ai bienvenue
vous avez rejoint journaliste politique
au Figaro votre votre analyse justement
en face à ce qu'a dit Pascal Perrineau
ce sera plus compliqué du coup pour
Emmanuel Macron et pour Marine Le Pen
qu'en 2017 cette fois oui et ce sera
tellement compliqué sachant
qu'effectivement la fracture est
sociologique et de revenus et de
diplômes que là l'une Tom l'autre vont
essayer de la surmonter par des
subterfuges
très visibles chez Emmanuel Macron qui
consiste quoi qu'il en dise à être à se
placer sur le terrain de la morale et
diaboliser l'adversaire il a dit tout à
l'heure à deux ans la morale je ne fais
pas de morale pas du tout mais en fait
on a entendu Bruno Le Maire sur une
radio ce matin parler de la collectif de
la France qui serait en péril si jamais
Emmanuel Macron si jamais pardon Marine
Le Pen était élu et de son côté Marine
Le Pen plus
j'allais dire subtilement de façon moins
apparente mais elle le répète quand même
elle le Martel quand même
elle sous-entend qu'en fait Emmanuel
Macron n'aime pas la France puisque en
captant le mot national
auquel elle
qui remplace si vous voulez le mot
nationalisme Marine Le Pen nationaliste
elle n'est pas nationale ça veut rien
dire national mais en captant ce mot
elle veut s'arranger le monopole de la
défense des intérêts de la nation donc
pas facile en fait véritablement de
retrouver des repères de posture de
diabolisation antagonistes ça sera donc
pas une réplique de 2017 Mélenchon
faisant de roi non Mélenchon n'y crois
pas pour la bonne raison que le
les directives des états majeurs
nationaux peu de poids en réalité sur
les comportements des électeurs ce qui
est important c'est la tonalité qui a
créé sa déclaration d'hier soir vous
souvenez que l'autre fois il avait mis à
peu près une semaine bon
en ayant le poisson autour d'une
consultation militante etc pour ne pas
prendre clairement position là hier soir
tout le monde a entendu la tétrale la
tétralogie répétée quatre fois vous ne
devez pas donner une voix à Madame Le
Pen ça crée un climat mais je suis pas
sûr que ça fasse bouger énormément les
les voix en réalité parce que il y a une
constante dans les dans cet électorat
dans tous les sondages on voit une
répartition qui relativement équilibrée
et ce qui est très intéressant c'est que
l'électorat ne me Jean-Luc Mélenchon
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
n'est pas à Jean-Luc mais non
c'est à dire que le vote utile a amené
sur la candidature Mélenchon des
électeurs qui ne sont pas mélanconiens
qui sont des socialistes en déshérence
qui sont des écologistes déçues par
exemple on a pris aujourd'hui avec
Madame coffinte au maire et la mairie de
Paris qui est militante de repécologie
les Verts à voter mais bon le soupçonne
d'autres d'avoir fait la même chose donc
il a en fait été un agrégateur de viande
de gauche qui voulait être présent au
second tour mais qui ne sont pas tous
loin de là des insoumis et je pense que
dans cette frange là les 10% disons
qu'ils ont rejoint et qu'il faut à peu
près la moitié de son électorat je pense
que ça leur sera plus facile de voter
contre ce Marine Le Pen qui a la
fraction vraiment dure de la France
insoumise parce qu'on parle d'un tiers
un tiers un tiers parce qu'elle quand je
dis voter Macron
servir du vote Macron pour barrer la
route à Marine Le Pen le recours à la
diabolisation faudra voir comment ça va
évoluer hier soir en effet quand on
regardait les matrices de trans cancer
de l'institut Ipsos c'était à peu près
trois tiers
un tiers
dans l'abstention 33%
choisissaient
choisi ces Marine Le Pen 33% choisissait
le président mais tout cela va évoluer
d'abord il y a eu en effet
l'intervention de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
est beaucoup moins ambigu qu'elle ne
l'était qu'elle ne l'était il y a 5 ans
mais
Macron mais je partage le sentiment le
sentiment de Claude si vous voulez
aujourd'hui qui contrôle son électorat à
peu près personne donc les élections
d'où l'incertitude d'où l'importance des
des effets de campagne dans
l'entre-deux-tours en effet on a
l'impression si vous voulez que on verra
si ça évolue dans les jours qui viennent
mais il y a un élément de fragilité dans
le dispositif de d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a pas fait une
bonne campagne de premier tour c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire
voilà il a pas fait campagne et quand il
a fait campagne véritablement ça ne
sonnait pas juste et là jusqu'à
maintenant on ne peut pas dire que
l'entrée en campagne de second tour
était une franche réussite le discours
d'hier soir n'était pas un discours
auquel d'habitude Emmanuel Macron nous
nous habitue voilà on a l'impression
d'un président relativement isolé qui a
du mal à trouver son style difficile de
retourner dans l'arène peut-être
difficile de retourner dans l'armée
c'est sur quel terrain va jouer le
second tour moi je crois beaucoup au
terrain c'est-à-dire l'agenda et
l'agenda contrairement à ce qu'on croit
n'est pas tellement fait par les
politiques souvenez-vous que dans tout
l'automne l'agenda a été fait par là
clairement par Zemmour qui a imposé son
thème la France aux français le grand
remplacement et puis tout à coup on a vu
l'affaire
ukrainienne envahir le débat et ça tu es
Zemmour d'ailleurs et propulser et un
manuel Macron et puis tout à coup on a
vu arriver
le pouvoir d'achat est tout et là c'est
Marine Le Pen qui s'est engouffré parce
que la thématique pouvoir d'achat était
pour elle très favorable et donc quelle
thématique va s'imposer dans des bas de
l'intro de tour alors qui à l'heure nous
parlons nous ne le savons pas un Judith
justement sur Éric Zemmour 7,2 %, il a
raté donc son pari de rassembler les
droites c'est ce qu'il voulait faire oui
il a absolument raté alors lui se
console en disant
la droite à moins de 5% la candidate de
la droite a moins de 5% Valérie Pécresse
qui lui cru si on m'avait dit moi qui ne
faisait pas de politique que j'en serais
bon le problème sans problème c'est que
voilà le problème c'est qu'il est parti
de plus haut et qu'il l'a fait que
descendre après une entrée tonitruante
en campagne et en s'invitant même dans
le club des candidats capables d'accéder
au second il a payé l'Ukraine comme
disait évidemment il a payé l'Ukraine
parce que quand on regarde il y a eu
plusieurs accidents de campagne le
d'accueillir les réfugiés Ukrainiens en
état énorme mais avant ça il y avait
cette déclaration sur les enfants
handicapés qui n'ont pas pour la plupart
avec il dit leur place dans les
établissements
de l'éducation nationale depuis cette
déclarations je pense que la dramatisme
de la dramaturgie du moment
a fait apparaître aux Français que il
avait pas les épaules c'est pas
tellement ce qu'il a dit c'est les
Français ont pas vu ont pas vu
Zemmour en chef de guerre dans ces
circonstances dans les circonstances
aussi tragiques je crois que c'est ça
qui s'est passé
il y a deux choses qu'il faut avoir en
tête c'est que le second tour d'une
présidentielle se joue aussi quand même
pas mal effectivement sur la
présidentialité malgré tout donc je
pense que Emmanuel Macron a fait une
campagne de deuxième tour dès le premier
tour mais il avait pas vraiment non plus
le choix parce que c'est le problème de
tous les sortants et l'un des l'un des
gros problèmes de tous ces adversaires
c'était la capacité incarnée et nous
quand on a
regardez les traits d'images des
différents candidats bon il y en avait
un qui avait la statue il y en avait une
qui comprenait les problèmes des gens
c'est Emmanuel Macron et celle qui
comprend les problèmes des gens celle
qui est comme moi c'est Marine le
problème c'est que je moi est-ce que je
présiderais la France pas sûr et donc
c'est l'un des problèmes qu'elle a eu en
2017 est-ce que ça va se reproduire
passion non plus mais ça ça n'a pas
changé alors il y a juste une chose à
laquelle à mon avis il faut faire
attention c'est l'illusion d'optique que
les scores seraient comparables
l'électeur Macron j'ai insiste n'a rien
à voir avec ce qui était en 2017
notamment parce que le lecteur à Macron
c'est fondamentalement l'électorat
conservateur au sens donc il s'est
droitisé oui mais clairement
préserver le statu quo l'électorat
Mélenchon c'est l'électorat socialiste
en fait donc effectivement il va être
beaucoup plus facile à convaincre de de
rentrer dans une logique de front
républicain pour toute cette partie
nouvelle c'est à dire en fait le noyau
dur on le sait mais on est dur de
Mélenchon c'est que 10%. donc
effectivement il y a toute une moitié de
cette électorat qui est déjà à peu près
acquise à Macron en revanche dans les
lecteurs à le il y a maintenant un petit
bout qui vient de finir aussi le petit
bout qui n'est pas parti chez Macron qui
a déserté Pécresse et l'autre partie de
chez Zemmour et là là il y a une vraie
ligne de fracture en fait qu'on
sous-estime à l'intérieur de l'extrême
droite entre ceux qui font le pari la
recomposition de la droite et ceux qui
font le pari du nouveau clivage peuple
contredite ils ne sont pas d'accord et
ils sont pas prêts de se mettre d'accord
donc là il y a division justement on va
revenir sur LR ce parti traditionnel qui
effectivement a connu une vraie
dégringolade le Parti socialiste
également donc ces deux parties ont
littéralement été laminés lors de ce
scrutin on va écouter Valérie Pécresse
c'était aujourd'hui lors du
rassemblement enfin de la réunion des
républicains
du batailler sur deux fronts contre le
camp du président sortant et contre
celui des extrêmes ce soir le réflexe du
vote utile à jouer à plein et le peuple
de France a voté et son verdict s'impose
à nous
ce résultat est évidemment une déception
personnelle et collective
j'assume en responsabilité
toute ma part dans cette défaite malgré
les profondes divergences que j'ai
martelé tout au long de la campagne je
voterai en conscience Emmanuel Macron
pour empêcher l'arrivée au pouvoir de
Marine Le Pen et le chaos qui en
résulterait c'était hier qu'elle
appelait à voter Emmanuel Macron Pascal
Perrineau donc ça clairement c'est une
claque pour Valérie Pécresse elle a
divisée par 4 d'après ce que j'ai lu le
score de François Fillon d'abord c'est
une humiliation pour LR est-ce que c'est
une question de survie aujourd'hui ah
oui oui bien sûr au fond ce qui est
arrivé au Parti socialiste en 2017
arrivent aujourd'hui à la principale
force de la droite française les
républicains ça a été véritablement une
véritable descente aux enfers parce que
il ne faut pas oublier tout de même
qu'il y a maintenant quelques mois juste
après son investiture dans une primaire
fermée
elle pouvait très bien s'inviter de
nombreuses enquêtes d'intention de votre
pouvait s'inviter dans un second tour il
y avait même des intentions de vote de
second tour qui montrait sa capacité à
battre Emmanuel Macron au tout début de
la campagne quel chemin parcouru et quel
chemin parcouru dans le sens d'un
véritable dévissage dévissage donc c'est
comment l'explique en deux mots pour
notre public international effectivement
a vu Valérie Pécresse triomphe au début
à la fois une campagne en est qui à
partir de ce fameux meeting raté est une
campagne qui n'a pas trouvé son style
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
deuxièmement peut-être trop d'importance
prêtée j'allais dire à l'électorat LR
qui pouvait être séduit par la droite de
la droite au fond
Valérie Pécresse a peut-être fait un
mauvais diagnostic certes monsieur
Ciotti fait 40 % mais fait 40 % chez au
fond les adhérents LR et quand on
regardait les électeurs LR c'était tout
à fait différent vous aviez un tropisme
de ces chercheurs pour Emmanuel Macron
et on l'a vu ni alors ça explique
qu'aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron est le
grand candidat conservateur parce que il
a été rejoint par tous ces électeurs
elle est et ça il y a eu certainement
autour
de la candidate LR autour de Valérie
Pécresse il y a une erreur de diagnostic
il y a une erreur de diagnostic il y a
une obsession du côté de la droite de la
droite et ils ont pas vu ce qui se
passait au centre droit où là il y a eu
une fuite mais une fuite
je l'ai écrit dès le début ça me sautait
aux yeux c'est que en réalité ils ont
fait un truc mortel en politique qu'ils
ont laissé Zemmour mettre la main sur
l'agenda de Madame Pécresse quand il a
dit vous êtes la candidate de 20h02
c'est vous qui irez annoncez je vote
Macron elle n'a eu de cesse de démontrer
qu'elle n'était pas macroniste donc elle
a fait campagne exclusivement contre
Macron pendant que ces électeurs se
barraient chez Zemmour là il y a eu de
la part de Stéphanie des gens qui
l'entourent une erreur stratégique
majeure à mon sens
ce que vous dites c'est une conséquence
à mon avis pas une cause je m'explique
quand Valérie Pécresse déclare sa
candidature à la fin de l'été elle dit
premier discours Emmanuel Macron n'est
qu'une pâle copie de la droite et à
partir de souvent là c'est fichu on ne
vote pas pour quelqu'un qui accuse son
adversaire de l'avoir copié et donc en
disant de stratégie aussi la grosse
erreur la première erreur elle est tout
de suite et elle est là elle est plus
ancienne alors si je peux me permettre
d'aider les législatives de 2017 LR
aurait dû faire un vrai Adji enamento
dans le sens probablement je pense en
réalité quand même qu'il y a un fond de
vrai dans le diagnostic de Zemmour mais
c'est un autre sujet je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en parler au législative
mais en revanche un truc qui est sûr
c'est qu'ils ont mal interprété et le
patron socialiste alors les européennes
ils n'ont pas vu le message
et en fait d'ailleurs le sport
le mandat soit disant qu'ils auraient
reçu au régional et aux municipales
enfin et ça le PS a fait la même erreur
les verres ont fait la même erreur c'est
une erreur maintenant hyper commune
puisque le PS s'est enféré lorsqu'elle a
droite était au pouvoir en surfant sur
ces 10 régions
en fait qui sont installés
que ce soit Valérie Pécresse ou un autre
le positionnement qui consistait à dire
Macron nous copie et à s'écarteler entre
les positions incarnées par Iris
rusciotti et l'aile
moins dur de la droite c'était fichu
donc la personnalité de Valérie Pécresse
a sans doute pas arrangé les choses la
façon dont elle a conduit la campagne
évidemment elle était en contemplois
très très fort sur les thèmes réguliers
personne tout le monde disait
mais la différence c'est que autant elle
est a fait une erreur stratégique autant
du point de vue du Parti socialiste
c'est autre chose c'est qu'il y avait
pas de stratégie du tout il y avait une
mauvaise candidate et pas de stratégie
donc le résultat ne pouvait être que
calamiteux parce qu'ils étaient soumis
de la même façon à une double attraction
d'un côté Macron qui récupérerait les
modéré de l'autre côté mais un son qui
récupérait les radicaux et donc il est
pris en sandwich elle a de faire une
comme
[Musique]
ils avaient déjà vécu ça alors que les
LR se sont quand même vraiment fourvoyés
sur le message envoyé par les
Européennes de 2019 le score de Bel-Ami
serait dû être vraiment le Bel water
comment dire en anglais ils l'ont pas
compris et c'est incroyable ce qu'ils
peuvent s'en sortir c'est deux parties
est-ce qu'ils vont renaître de leur
cendre à la fois le Parti socialiste et
ce parti à droite LR de droite
républicaine faut jamais dire jamais
voilà qui composition politique continue
en France après son échec absolument
terrible en 1969 au travers de la
candidature de fer le Parti socialiste
quelques années plus tard est rentré
dans une dynamique unitaire qui dix ans
après la mort
à 49,2 bien sûr donc voilà simplement ce
qu'il y a de plus compliqué c'est qu'au
fond il y a un vieux clivage quel
clivage gauche-droite que nous
connaissons depuis deux siècles qui est
qui est toujours à l'œuvre la surface on
le voit sous la surface mais il y a un
nouveau clivage qui peut à peu c'est
imposé quel clivage que le président
adore présenter comme étant parce que
cet avantageux pour lui le clivage entre
les progressistes et les nationalistes
voilà et et là c'est vrai qu'il y a un
nouveau type de clivage ou dans ce
progressisme il y a à la fois des
électeurs de droite et de gauche et dans
le nationalisme ce qui est présenté
comme tel ce que j'appellerai plutôt moi
le National populisme il y a des
électeurs de droite de gauche et
d'ailleurs donc ce nouveau clivage il
met en tension le clivage gauche droite
il met en tension les deux principaux
appareils qui depuis 1958 ont organisé
la bipolarisation sous la 5ème à savoir
le grand parti conservateur et de
l'autre côté le Parti socialiste on peut
revenir ça reviendrait à ce clivage
traditionnel ou pas
et que donc Macron n'avait aucune chance
de faire plus de 3%. le problème c'est
que nous sommes actuellement dans notre
système tripolaire or les sont
fondamentalement instables la
bipolarisation ça fonctionne comme une
balance Robert ou la queue du chien
comme disait le troisième tripolaire
avec une gauche très très à gauche une
droite très très à droite et un grand
centre qui essaie de ramasser tout ce
qui est très à gauche ni très à droite
soundso dans l'art de la guerre explique
que les systèmes à des systèmes A3 ne
sont toujours
temporaire parce que ça termine toujours
par l'alliance de deux contre on ne peut
aucun système à trois n'est stable dans
la dans le temps je pense que la gauche
et la droite sont des invariants
culturels qui reviendront toujours je
pense que la social-démocratie
actuellement et derrière le rideau une
partie des sociodes démocrates ont été
Macron une autre partie a voté pour
Mélenchon mais la culture sociale
démocrate elle n'est pas morte le Parti
socialiste est nul il est dirigé par des
incapable mais cette culture sociale
démocrate ne disparaîtra pas parce que
il correspond à quelque chose de la même
façon de la culture de la droite
républicaine n'est pas mort hier soir
Macron Macron peut l'incarner quand même
plus facilement que Mélenchon pourrait
en Autriche comment le le le l'extrême
droite autrichienne j'ai pas donné les
sigles ça ne reste personne avait
complètement à une époque cannibalisée
la droite traditionnelle et finalement
les revenus et la même chose en Italie
oui
moi je pensais qu'ils peuvent renaître
de leur cendre à un moment donné en tout
cas pas tout de suite j'imagine c'est
vrai qu'il faut être prudent et que on
fait de la politique assez longtemps
pour pour ne pas pour se garder des
prédictions qui concernent l'avenir mais
néanmoins il me semble que la nouvelle
partition entre pour aller vite inclus
et exclu
rend forte probable la reconstitution
d'élite dissoute et la reconstitution on
peut plus
ignorer ce clivage là qui vraiment
est structurel maintenant dans la
société
ANOVA qui a mené le PS là où il en est
donc
c'est lorsqu'il y a eu cette fameuse
note qui disait le clivage social en
gros il possédant contre les
travailleurs voilà ça n'existe plus nous
ça va être les minorités sexuelles
ethnique non je sais tout à fait mais
mais Zemmour lui par exemple il y croit
beaucoup ça aussi de l'autre côté il est
pendant finalement de Terra Nova à côté
droite on va dire donc ils sont par ici
d'ailleurs est un peu perdu aussi pour
le moment mais il répond à la stratégie
Terra Nova qui a été appliquée par la
gauche française
pas pour les démocrates notamment qui
les emmène systématiquement dans le mur
alors ce que ce qui est ce que le
problème c'est de leadership en réalité
la gauche est à gauche la terre
Mitterrand la ressuscite et la rassemble
et même chose à droite à d'autres
époques le problème c'est
qu'actuellement la droite et la gauche
classique Instit professionnels ont un
problème de leadership absolument
tragique incontestable personne ne peut
prendre le ramasser le drapeau et dire
suivez-moi donc tant qu'il y aura pas de
Sarkozy n'a pas été remplacé
par Macron oui
on va refaire justement essayer de voir
qu'elles vont être les clés de ce match
pendant 15 jours parce qu'elle Perrineau
comment alors ça va être un peu le grand
écart pour vous le disiez Marine Le Pen
qui doit donc récupérer des années
électorat de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
récupérer également l'électorat d'Éric
Zemmour qui a appelé à voter Marine Le
Pen donc elle peut réaliser ce grand
écart Marine Le Pen ça va pas être
simple la tâche n'est pas facile la
tâche n'est pas facile elle n'a jamais
réussi à le faire ni dans des élections
par exemple régionales les élections
européennes c'est pas du tout la même
logique puisque ce sont des élections à
la proportionnelle elle n'a pas réussi
jusqu'à maintenant à le faire mais mais
attention alors pourquoi dit ça parce
que vous avez en 2017 un anti le pénis
évident le fameux front républicain que
Macron cherche aussi plus ou moins
habilement aujourd'hui a ressuscité il
n'y avait pas d'antim agronismes il y
avait pas de sortant 5 ans plus tard
tout a changé il y a un anti-machronisme
qui est aussi solide que l'anti le
pénismes qui s'est exprimé sur le plan
social on l'a vu avec le mouvement des
gilets jaunes et que Madame Marine Le
Pen va tenter dans les 15 jours qui
viennent de faire réexister à son profit
elle va chercher à être le vecteur de
cet anti-machronisme pluriel
divers certes viscérale qui a
souvenons-nous tout de même au moment de
2018-2019 il y avait une hostilité
vis-à-vis de la personnalité du
président qui était majeur et on envoie
les traces je regardais hier les traits
d'image par exemple du candidat
président Emmanuel Macron c'est vrai que
sur le terrain de la présidentialité de
la capacité à représenter la France à la
crise j'allais dire il y a pas photo
voilà gérer des crises mais en revanche
et c'est très important tout ce qui est
au fond proximité
empathie et on sait très bien
aujourd'hui que les figures d'autorité
ne sont plus simplement verticales elles
ont de dimension horizontale elles ont
une dimension de guerre d'empathie et
bien là il est pas mal placé il est très
mal président
sur cette sur cette logique est-ce que
le plafond de verre dont on a beaucoup
parlé quand on parle de Marine Le Pen
aujourd'hui on parle plus vraiment de la
frontière ce fameux pronostic comment
effectivement elle l'a brisée elle peut
le briser je pense que évidemment le le
front anti de peine n'est plus une
imagino mais je pense que ça existe
encore un peu quand je vois hier soir
quand même dans la minute qui suit de
Poutou à Valérie Pécresse pratiquement
tous les leaders sauf les soutiens
naturels de varier le Pen dire pas une
voix pour elle ça veut dire qu'il reste
encore quelque chose que l'extrême
droite en France à part encore quand
même des gens que son programme sur les
thèmes de l'immigration sont référendum
sur l'immigration qui viendrait très
très vite et qui mettrait à mal en
termes de principes que nous considérons
à taroaraison comme républicain ou en
tout cas intangible je pense que tout ça
sa réactive quand même des choses il y a
quand même beaucoup de gens qui ne qui
ont beau détesté Macron et qui ont quand
même beaucoup beaucoup de mal à aller
voter pour pour Marine Le Pen je pense
pas du tout qu'elle fasse une campagne
dans l'anti macronisme je pense que elle
va faire une campagne beaucoup plus
intelligente parce qu'elle est fine elle
va faire une campagne comme agrégateur
de mécontentement ce qui est un petit
peu différent c'est à dire que son
terrain c'est la vie chère c'est la
pompe à essence c'est l'électricité à la
fin du mois
la déclaration hier soir c'est j'appelle
tous ceux qui n'ont pas voté pour
Emmanuel Macron à rejoindre mon
rassemblement parce que quand on regarde
les sondages le
pour qui ne voteriez-vous à aucun prix
elle est quand même beaucoup moins bien
placé que lui je crois qu'il y a que 38%
des gens dans un récent sondage qui
disait je ne voterai jamais pour Macron
alors qu'il y en avait à peu près 50 qui
disait je ne voterai jamais pour Marine
Le Pen on va faire un affrontement
sauf Macron contre tout sauf le Pen là
et l'autre vont à modifier leur
programme avec cette avantage dont
dispose Emmanuel Macron d'être le
président sortant donc quand il parle
des cordons de la bourse et du quoi
qu'il en coûte car il en parle et il a
déjà commencé à en parler et ça va
continuer on pense même à dire que la
retraite à 65 ans ça pourrait se
discuter les gens vont le croire parce
qu'ils l'ont vu à l'oeuvre ils l'ont vu
alors en 1981 aussi on avait un tout
sogis car versus un tout sauf Mitterrand
et on avait un par exemple on a fait un
Chirac qui disait une chose et penser le
contraire et là moi ce qui me ce qui
m'amuse un peu ses émotions parce que on
a eu quand même sur ce plateau monsieur
Missia qui une seconde avant que Zemmour
appelle à voter pour Le Pen qui nous
disait qu'il voyait pas pourquoi il le
ferait et que lui il devrait pas que
c'était une bonne idée il y a quand même
beaucoup de gens dans le sur l'idée du
plafond de verre ça a été aussi un des
gros ressorts du humourisme si je puis
dire c'est à dire tant qu'on est
l'extrême tant qu'on aille que les gens
d'en bas bah les gens d'en bas il reste
en bas donc il y a quand même une
stratégie alternative on pourrait dire
plus 30 pieds en fait d'alliance
improbables sur le papier entre les
élites les plus aisés les plus
réactionnaires et le peuple lumppen
prolétariat qui n'a rien à perdre est-ce
que dans vos études vous repérez une
fraction d'électorates et Moore qui ne
veut pas voter le pays oui ça existe
mais elle est toute petite et c'est là
qu'on voit la différence comme toujours
entre les cadres et les électeurs je
n'ai pas dit que c'était vrai des
électeurs de Zemmour d'abord parce que
les électeurs de Zemmour
mis à part ceux qui viennent de Fillon
qui sont vraiment dans la lignée de la
manif pour tous et qui sont cohérents
avec eux-mêmes ils sont quand même aussi
issus du Front national une grosse
partie des cadres aussi mais là c'est
pour cette raison là que il ne croit pas
dans les chances de Marine Le Pen parce
que ceux qui sont issus du RN savent les
limites du RN aussi
on n'arrive pas à 51% si vous ajoutez
Zemmour plus
il est pas encore à Marine Le Pen donc
pas beaucoup mais c'est surtout sur
Mélenchon qui aurait une grosse illusion
à croire voilà 60 secondes
pas 100%
et bien sûr la participation sera plus
faible
important à ce second tour où est-ce que
les abstentionnistes vont continuer à
s'abstenir au deuxième tour ah oui non
non plus certainement une partie des
abstentionnistes qui devant le choix
bipolaire simple en effet ce qui sont
absolument au premier tour qui peuvent
très bien se déplacer se déplacer au
second on a toujours ce mouvement ce
mouvement léger mais vous allez aussi
avoir de multiples électeurs du premier
tour qui vont être soumis et qui sont
aujourd'hui soumis à des pressions
contradictoires qu'ils vont estimer
comme étant insupportable par exemple
les lecteurs mélenchonistes qui se dit
voilà j'ai entendu tout de même pique
pendre d'Emmanuel Macron je suis d'une
vieille culture de gauche donc je vais
pas me rallier à Madame Le Pen mais tout
de même aller voter Macron non donc ça
comment vous résolvez cette pression
contra que vous ressentez en vous restez
chez soi c'est ce que j'appelle les
députés du premier tour par exemple les
électeurs de la salle qui se
caractérisent par un détestation de tous
les politiques ils ça sera très très
difficile de seconde tour mais il faut
pas le peine probablement non mais je
pense qu'ils vont beaucoup rester à la
ferme complètement est-ce qu'on va se
retrouver avec des clivages
Judith van drop des clivages sur les
programmes c'est à dire c'est
qu'effectivement il y aura une vraie
différence entre la fameuse retraite à
65 ans pour Emmanuel Macron à 60 ans
pour Marine Le Pen est-ce qu'ils vont
est-ce qu'on va retrouver ce type de
clivage sur des programmes pendant ces
vacances
commencez à dire que on pouvait discuter
sinon l'objectif du moins de la modalité
des retraites
je crois qu'il est prêt à séparer de pas
mal de choses et à dire que il prendra
son temps pour les mesures les plus
abrasives
la majorité des lecteurs se font
complètement des programmes
est-ce qu'il va bouger son programme
essentiellement fournir des armes à
l'adversaire mais oui bien alors sur le
duel par exemple puisqu'il nous reste 5
minutes ce fameux duel ce qui peut
vraiment largement gagner par Emmanuel
Macron on s'en souvient il y a 5 ans oui
le fameux le débat le 2h le est-ce que
c'est aperçu que effectivement Emmanuel
Macron pourrait gagner à nouveau en tout
cas elle elle a un avantage elle parle
de très bas elle l'avait tellement raté
la dernière fois que c'est assez
difficilement
80 il pouvait pas faire pire et du coup
il s'est dit il faut que je joue petit
bras et l'autre lui a servi sur un
plateau et progresser et puis il y a
toujours un truc dangereux c'est quand
vous avez plié quelqu'un au tennis en
trois sets et que vous le rejouez 15
jours après vous jouez toujours moins
bien que la première fois ça c'est
beaucoup les métaphores de tennis
Emmanuel Macron même métaphore tennis
oui et puis si vous voulez là il y a
aussi c'est l'homme d'un passé donc ça
va être très différent et peut-être même
comme disait Giscard non Mitterrand face
à Giscard l'homme d'un passif
elle va pas se priver de l'attaquer
là-dessus et beaucoup de Français
considèrent que certes Emmanuel Macron
sur certains dossiers oui ça a été un
plus mais sur beaucoup de dossiers il
considère que ça a été à moi en
particulier sur ce que beaucoup de
ministres nous expliquaient encore hier
que tout allait beaucoup mieux en France
qui avait moins de chômage que le
pouvoir d'achat avait augmenté et oui
mais le gros problème c'est que les
Français dans leur dans leur
conditions voilà ils ne partagent pas ce
diagnostic extrêmement optimiste qu'on
entendait qu'on entend encore ce matin
la fraction d'électorats qui susceptible
de qui est indécise jusqu'au bout et
susceptible de lancer de côté un autre
je pense que au bout du compte ce qui
compte dans la tête des gens c'est
lequel habite le rôle lequel est capable
de porter le costume je crois que ça
c'est clair
en 80 il faut un président à la France
alors qu'il était alors personne ne
doutait de la présidentialité de
Mitterrand et voilà et c'est ça
qui est fondamental et il y a une autre
chose c'est que par contre Giscard dans
des 2480 a pris vraiment Mitterrand de
haut au lieu de jouer l'empathie avec le
monopole du cœur il a il lui a demandé
le cours du dodgemark et il était pas
loin de ça quand ils ont parlé de
l'écure en 2017 je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez vous lisez vos filles vous ne
maîtrisez pas vos dossiers la phrase il
va peut-être pas la refaire donc
peut-être que là on le sent vraiment
très modeste peut-être que il peut
éviter l'écueil du débat de 80 à lui là
dessus qu'est-ce que vous en pensez oui
mais lui il a un problème parce que il
dit qu'il veut éviter la diabolisation
parce que il se rend bien compte des
limites de l'exercice que ça incite
certaines personnes à dire mais après
tout on veut m'interdire sur le plan
moral de voter pour Marine Le Pen je
refuse cette ou case mais en même temps
son quand il dit il faut
polariser les attaques c'est ce qu'il
dit à ses troupes sur le côté technique
et le côté a praticable du programme de
Marine Le Pen s'il fait ça ça va donner
un débat alors là
personne ne pourra suivre
son hyper agressivité est apparu à
moitié folle de colère et de haine donc
les Français ne voulaient pas ça il
voulait des personnages présidentielles
il voulait pas une incompétence qui
était sorti en premier à mon avis ce qui
était le plus ressorti c'était c'était
sa brutalité c'est c'était les Français
ont l'habitude contrairement à ce qu'on
pense qu'à ce niveau là les politiques
se tiennent bien
alors aussi
dans le rôle là j'ai regardé hier les
images de la présidentialité chez Marine
Le Pen elle est partout en hausse et
elle rassemble beaucoup changé ça a
beaucoup changé par rapport à 2017 ou
plus hallucinant c'est quelle est la
candidate qui vous rassure le plus quand
il vous rassure vous inquiète alors
Zemmour était celui qui de loin qui
était le plus de gens et elle elle était
un peu elle était un point mais devant
Macron sur vous rassure comme quoi rien
y jouer c'est sûr il reste donc 15 jours
de campagne merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous merci Pascal Perrineau Merci à
VOUS Judith vandrobe merci Mathieu
douare et Merci à VOUS Claude veille
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
voici avec nous sur France 24
[Musique]